der günstigste 992 GT3 Deutschlands
rollt wieder und das nicht nur heute
sondern hoffentlich für immer denn ich
habe ziemlich große Pläne mit dem Auto
bevor wir uns darum aber kümmern und ich
euch an diesen Plänen teilhaben lasse
bin ich euch erstmal noch einige Sachen
Schuld neben den Kosten die wir in
diesem Video endlich aufdröseln werden
um zu schauen ob es wirklich der
günstigste 992 GT3 Deutschlands ist
natürlich auch der Carport meine Damen
und Herren anschnallen fertig machen ich
wünsche euch ganz viel Spaß mit dem
carpon meines 992
gt3s
[Musik]
little want
want i
can'tce
[Musik]
was für ein Traum ich kann es selber
immer noch nicht glauben dass das Auto
fertig ist dass es fährt und vor allem
dass es mir gehört ich stehe extra vor
der Arbeit auf um irgendwie noch eine
Runde fahren zu können und das Auto mit
allen Sinnen aufzusaugen also es ist
wirklich keine Selbstverständlichkeit
und ich bin über alle Berge aber dieser
Traum kommt zu einem Preis ein Preis den
wir gleich aufdröseln und die Kosten
sind schon wirklich saftig irgendwann
kam mir die Frage wie kann ich Geld mit
dem Auto verdienen und nein ich rede
nicht davon das Auto jetzt wieder zu
verkaufen denn irgendwann ist mir
aufgefallen egal ob ich mit dem Auto
fahre oder ob das Auto steht jede Woche
jeder Tag jede Stunde jede Minute
verliert dieses Auto Geld ja die gt3s
sind schon ziemlich wertstabil aber Geld
verdienen tut man nicht wirklich gerade
dann nicht wenn man das Auto fährt und
vielleicht sogar wie ich es dieses Jahr
machen möchte auf der Rennstrecke fährt
irgendwann kam mir die Idee wie ich mit
dem Auto tatsächlich Geld verdienen
könnte und wie ich den Traum von
weiteren noch anderen Autos
verwirklichen kann und wie es vielleicht
jeder andere von euch auch kann genau
das könnte vielleicht sogar eine
komplette neue Serie auf diesem Kanal
werden bevor ich euch davon aber erzähle
und bevor wir das durchrech und
probieren genau das zu tun erstmal zu
den Kosten und dafür zurück zum
Schreibtisch also für euch zurück zum
Schreibtisch ich fahre erstmal noch eine
Runde saahtag bzw Abrechnung die große
Frage ist mein 992 GT3 der günstigste
992 GT3 Deutschlands erstmal zur
Einordnung der aktuell günstigste
angebotene 992 GT3 Deutschlands auf
mobile mit 21 000 km gelaufen wir
schauen uns natürlich nicht die Autos an
die 100.000 km gelaufen haben sondern
der der am ehesten am nähesten an mein
rankommt liegt mit 21 000 gelaufenen
kilomet bei
195500 € kein Carbondach was meiner hat
aber genau wie meiner kein Lift und
ungefähr ähnliche Ausstattung das ist
schon ganzes Brett und die Preise sind
in den letzten Monaten tatsächlich
gefallen was mir nicht unbedingt in die
Karten spielt wenn ich wirklich den
günstigsten 992 GT3 Deutschlands haben
möchte bezahlt habe ich für meinen am
Ende 133 000 € brutto in kaputtem
Zustand das muss man sich auf der Zunge
zergehen lassen 133 000 € ohne zu wissen
ob ich das Auto überhaupt mal wieder auf
die Straße bekomme das ist ungefähr so
viel wie ich damals für die
projektwohnung bezahlt habe was aber
auch eine Immobilie ist die mir
monatlich wieder mehr Geld reinbringt
und die Stein auf Stein auf Stein ist
auf jeden Fall B deutlich sicherere
Investment als ein kaputtes Auto aber
viel wichtiger die Frage was hat mich
die Reparatur gekostet weil am Ende hat
alles funktioniert und das Auto fährt
wieder steht bestens da on top habe ich
für die Reparatur noch mal vi und f 5000
€ ausgegeben bedeutet Einkaufspreis mit
Reparaturkosten zusammen lag mein Auto
bei
187000 € was ein richtiges Brett ist
denn sind einige Taus € günstiger als
der nächst günstige 992 GT3 auf mobil
man muss aber dazu sagen meiner ist und
bleibt ein Unfallwagen was der hier
angebotene für 195 000 € nicht ist und
geht man davon aus den Händler von den
195.000 noch ein Stückchen runter zu
handeln kommen wir gefährlich nah an den
Preis für meinen Unfallwagen ran lohnt
es sich also jetzt genauso ein Projekt
zu machen würde ich es irgendwem von
Euch empfehlen ganz klar nein wenn ihr
absolute Experten seid und genau wisst
was ihr tut dann könnt ihr ein paar Taus
€o vielleicht sparen oder wenn ihr sogar
noch günstiger einkauft für jeden
anderen lasass die Finger davon so viel
Geld für ein Auto auszugeben ohne zu
wissen ob es überhaupt irgendwann mal
wieder fertig wird ist völlig Banane ich
hatte Glück dass es am Ende funktioniert
hat und bin damit mega happy weil ich
natürlich auch Content machen kann in
allen anderen Fällen hätte es nicht
funktioniert oder würde ich keine
Youtube Videos machen hätte das ein
richtiger re Fall werden könen
abschließend gilt es zu sagen ja mein
Auto ist der günstigste 992 GT3
Deutschlands all das was ich immer
wollte aber ich wer nicht ich wenn ich
die Kosten selber tragen wollen würde
und mir nicht schon Gedanken gemacht
hätte wie ich mit dem Auto etwas mehr
Geld verdienen kann bevor ich euch davon
aber erzähle mir den Mund weiter vlich
Rede Deckel ab Pot hoch und ein
schluckwser dank meines Partners a ab
keinen normalen schluckwasser sondern
einen mit Geschmack gerade in den Phasen
in denen ich neue Ideen habe oder schon
knöcheltief in Projekten stecke vergesse
ich alles um mich vernünftig zu schlafen
vernünftig zu en und vor allem genug zu
trinken seitdem ich aber Erb entdeckt
habe ist Schluss damit und mein Ziel von
zinh lit Leitungswasser am Tag ist
schneller erreicht als ich gucken kann
das dank diesen kleinen duftpots durch
die ihr beim Trinken von normalem
Leitungswasser das Gefühl habt irgendwas
mit Geschmack zu euch zu nehmen obwohl
es nur normales Wasser ist mit über 55
verschiedenen Pots habt ihr genug
Auswahl um immer wieder durchzuwechseln
ohne dass ein Geschmack langweilig wird
easy mitzunehmen und der perfekte
Begleiter für Euren Alltag völlig egal
ob zu Hause im Gym Büro oder sonst und
ich meine ihr wisst wie süchtig ich nach
Mate bzw allg emin nach süßgetränken war
und airup ist die perfekte Lösung jetzt
auf den ersten Link in der
Videobeschreibung klicken und mit dem
Code Dave 91 10% über den gesamten
Februar aufs ganze Sortiment bei a
sparen Auschecken jetzt viel Spaß weiter
mit dem Video aber sei das alles mal
dahingestellt ich habe am Ende knapp 190
000 € ausgegeben und die Frage die mir
ganz natürlich kommt ist wie kriege ich
am besten das Geld wieder ohne das Auto
verkaufen zu müssen die Antwort scheint
auf den ersten Blick so einfach wie
genial eine eigene Sportwagenvermietung
also könnte ich fast sagen herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen Serie ich
gründe eine Sportwagenvermietung
Sternchen zusatznotiz vielleicht ich
rechne alles gemeinsam mit euch durch
schau mir alles an sprech mit Experten
und entscheide dann ob ich eine
Sportwagenvermietung Gründe ich meine
stellt es euch einfach mal vor ein
Unternehmen das die Möglichkeit schafft
all die Autos zu besitzen von denen man
immer geträumt hat und diese auch allen
anderen zugänglich macht völlig egal ob
Lamborghini Huracan M3 Touring C63 oder
991 Turbo und all das ohne scamy
Anbieter bei denen jeder Kunde Angst
haben muss Schäden angerechnet zu
bekommen die man gar nicht verursacht
hat oder sogar am vereinbarten Tag ohne
Auto im Regen stehen gelassen zu werden
all das sind keine überdramatisierung
sondern Situationen aus eigener
Erfahrung jetzt würde der ein oder
andere dazu noch sagen Achtung der
Automarkt fällt gerade komplett bricht
komplett in sich zusammen das ist aber
de facto falsch zumindest im neuen ELER
Bereich ST Muro einer der größten Auto
Youtuber hat ein ganzes Video darüber
gemacht wie der Markt gerade
zusammenbricht und es stimmt der fak
einfach nicht ich kann euch für genau
diese Informationen den Kanal forwheel
Trader empfehlen für jeden dene
Preisentwicklung im Autobereich gerade
bei superportwagen wirklich interessiert
ist dieser Kanal einsame Spitze und er
bewertet zumindest den gesamten US-Markt
alle paar Wochen zu allen relevanten
Autos und stuft es ein was wir gesehen
haben ist dass übers letzte Jahr die
Preise gefallen sind und sich das in den
letzten zwei oder drei Monaten schon
wieder absolut stabilisiert hat und das
in fast allen neuen ELER Bereichen klar
es gibt spezielle Modelle wie eine 997
GT2 die antizyklisch laufen oder 997 GT3
oder gt3s das hat alles nichts damit zu
tun ich rede von den Standardmodellen
und den Carrera SS und Turbo SS und auch
den 992s und 991.2 gt3s dieser Welt also
der Markt hat sich stabilisiert sieht
gerade nicht so aus als würde weiter
fallen und wir sind im Normalbereich
dort wo die Preise vor der Pandemie auch
waren während der Pandemie sind sie
unheimlich in die Höhen geschossen im
letzten Jahr ist der Markt dann komplett
wieder gefallen aber nur auf der das
Level von vor Pandemie also alles in
bester Ordnung und ich schätze es so ein
dass er jetzt in den nächsten 5 Monaten
nicht noch ewig weiter fällt aber ob der
992 GT3 überhaupt das richtige Auto
dafür ist was wir sonst noch alles
brauchen Versicherung Startkapital
Gründung wie wir das alles machen
probieren wir in den nächsten Videos
gemeinsam herauszufinden um das aber
vernünftig hinzubekommen brauchen wir
richtig viel vor allem richtig viel
Daten denn ich will natürlich mein
Risiko so klein wie möglich halten und
habe deswegen einen Fragebogen online
gestellt wo ich unheimlich dankbar wäre
wenn den jeder von euch ich ausfüllen
würde welches Auto würdet ihr Mieten zu
welchem Preis würdet ihr welches Auto
mieten woher kommt ihr und würdet ihr
überhaupt ein Auto mieten das und ein
paar andere Fragen sind in wenigen
Minuten beantwortet klickt also auf den
Link in der Videobeschreibung und tut
mir den Gefallen um die nächsten Folgen
so spannend wie möglich zu machen nicht
zuletzt würde es bei dieser Idee auch
wieder um ein riesiges Investment gehen
heißt ja nicht dass wir es nur beim 992
GT3 belassen sondern vielleicht noch
weitere Autos zulegen wollen also muss
ich alles bestmöglich planen auch um
euch bestmöglich mit auf die Reise
nehmen zu können welche Autos machen
Sinn welche Autos wollen wir haben wir
brauchen einen stabilen Webauftritt wie
sieht's aus mit flotten Management und
GPS Versicherung Ausfall von Autos
Verschleißteilen die Reifen der
Reinigung Kostenmanagement all das von
vorne bis hinten wollen wir uns
gemeinsam anschauen also vergesst nicht
den Kanal zu abonnieren auch um die
Gespräche mit autovermietungsexperten
nicht zu
verpassen wir sehen uns diese Woche
Sonntag schon wieder und nächste Woche
Sonntag geht es direkt mit dem nächsten
autovermietungsvideo weiter bleibt also
dabei und freut euch auf die nächsten
Videos